all right for people who are joining
this live stream
we are going to talk about modeling or
more specifically meta modelling
and so here's the basic concept
there are models that people use to
describe things
they might be a random walk
they might be diffusion
they might be diffusion-limited
aggregation they might be a
self-avoiding random walk
they might be an agent-based model of
some kind they might be voids they might
be lots of kinds of things or they might
be cellular automata or differential
equations or other kinds of things
we have good frameworks
for representing models that are based
on systems of ordinary differential
equations partial differential equations
etc
but we realized that although many
people have implemented these things
many times in wolfram language we don't
have
uh standardized frameworks
for implementing things like agent-based
models
and perhaps as a way to kind of get a
start and understanding that we could
look at our demonstrations project
and look for let's see we have a section
called models here we go models
and we have
uh models there we go
do you think multi-agent see there's a
good actually let's take this as a
sample of what kinds of things we're
talking about here
um
and uh
you know for example if we look down
this list
many of the things that are here we have
good frameworks for dealing with
modeling random processes substitution
systems trees
uh
you know discrete models of various
kinds cellular automata and so on this
one is sort of a holdout so let's let's
take a look at this and see what we can
understand about this
so for instance
if we
if we look at something like this
can somebody characterize what is really
going on is in a system like this
christopher perhaps
i don't know exactly what this one is
doing but
i mean i guess it's
i mean the way you normally implement
something like this is that you know you
have a bunch of you have a bunch of
agents and maybe they have different
parameters or different types and so on
and there's some
there's some piece of code that runs in
all of the agents
right
and the agents but but fundamentally
okay so this is some nearest neighbor
thing and whatever
okay update agents so i suspect that
there's a loop that has this kind of
form update agents all the time
do you think that's a fair claim so yeah
right and also probably there's a set of
you know there might be some set of
primitives that are used a lot like for
example you know find all the other
agents within radius x or something like
that
right but so
i mean many of them are also random i
assume
many probably have a random element to
them some of them don't probably
right so i think that's two two classes
probably right okay so so
there's
i i think we can i don't think it's
gonna matter much whether they have a
random element i think that we've got
that's just gonna be a thing which
doesn't depend on the environment
you know each agent
at each step whatever a step is
looks at its environment
and does something
and updates itself
do you think that's the typical pattern
or does it update
another thing as well maybe it uh and
perhaps also
and perhaps it spawns new agents
do you think it affects other agents or
do you think it only looks at itself it
only affects itself i would say it
should only affect itself
right and if there's some other code you
know if some other agent should be
affected by the actions of this this
agent then the other agent should just
look at the state of this agent and
figure out that it should do something
okay
so okay so let's assume that the state
you know there is a class of i don't
just i'm just trying to understand
actually so i'm by asking questions
so um there's a set of algorithms that
are for instance used to compute
optimization to to compute optimal
values and run optimization
like genetic programming
or various kinds of evolutionary
algorithms or physics-based algorithms
do you think that those are i mean
that's how they they work
i don't think those are agent-based
models i think those are a different
kind of model i think the genetic
programming
is um i think
okay so my claim is i you know maybe i'm
too steeped in the physics project but
genetic programming is a story of what
we're calling branchial space it's just
it doesn't matter where the things are
they don't care where they are i mean
they're obviously versions of of
studying evolutionary biology that care
where they are but fundamentally in
genetic programming all that matters is
you have this thing and it has this
genome and it's going to interact with
this thing that has that genome whereas
i think these agent-based models are
more often they have a notion of space
well but also i mean i think that
i i think
like if you had a genetic programming
angle to this
you'd probably do that like one level
higher or something like you you'd have
all your agents doing their thing and
then you use genetic programming to
determine you know what parameters are
the agents that you're spawning going to
have
right that's probably the more common
case
but but for the physics stuff
right i mean i guess
you know i i assume you're thinking
about stuff like you know end body
simulations where you have newton's
third law like that kind of thing right
yes okay but by the way we should add to
the the existing
existing stuff
we have our end body simulation function
which is you know a fine example
of
something where we have why do you think
it's agent-based it's not agent-based
it's an example of a modeling framework
okay fine it's like you know
yes we agree
right but it is sort of a little bit
like agents because look at this i mean
this has got see this is kind of
interesting right
this representation that it uses of its
state
and also i mean you can write an end
body simulation as an agent-based model
right there isn't
you know you can't have this sort of
self-contained code for each point and
and you know it's minus floating point
there everything will work
sure
right
um
so
okay here's another question for you so
here's another example whether you think
it's agent-based or not
so
uh when we model queuing networks so
first is it you know it can be seen as a
random process
you know things like computer servers
that that get requests or a
doctor's office or an airport or
something
a human-made system
are literally agents coming through
okay and the way you need to simulate
that's definitely a random element to it
um do you think that's an agent-based
model
i think that you could study it an
agent-based way but queuing theory has
advanced beyond that point so it has
kind of a more complete theory
but it isn't because once you get to
real-world systems you need to simulate
it to say as basically you need to
simulate there's no analytics probably
similar to this yeah
i mean i think the thing that we have to
understand is some
uh
just i'm sorry i'm just looking at this
little thing um
my gosh
okay
um
but the questions that uh roger is
posing they're helpful
uh
i mean they they they help to motivate
this idea of meta modeling itself which
we haven't we haven't necessarily
completely described yet at least in
this live stream for
uh for for other viewers i mean so part
of the idea is that on the one hand if
you look at that list that's presented
at the top some of these are very
fundamental models of computational
behavior such as cellular automata right
other
some of these models however
especially in practice
are modeled by
researchers who are we can say straying
somewhat from
from completely fundamental study of
computational behavior and we and what
we want to do with meta modeling
is to
establish a practice
for extracting from these less
computationally foundational models you
know simple underlying behavior so with
cellular automata it's already highly uh
simple so we can run these ca programs
we can see what they do but what roger's
asking is well with these other kinds
like with end body systems or with
queuing etc etc what you know can we
find
underlying very simple
rules or behavior models for describing
these and how do they relate and it
might be the case that with meta
modeling when you look in areas of
mathematical sciences or what's
sometimes known as complex systems
theory but is often in practice much
more applied it might very well be the
case that that undergirding these there
are simple
underlying models that actually have
quite a bit in common and that's really
what we're looking for in the end but
then yeah we're right but i mean more
practically at some level what we would
like to do
is something where we can say you know
agent-based model
of blah blah blah
and where we can write voids in one line
for example
that will be an example of an objective
here
i think the basic thing is just that
there's a whole class of these models
that when you say that you don't mean
james boyd
no no i mean
but b-o-i-ds yeah okay that's very
confusing
okay
okay but i i guess the point is just
that i mean boyd's being one of them
especially in sort of the complex
systems world they're just endless you
know endless agent-based models and
things like that right now there isn't
really a super concise way of writing
those
right i mean i think this is a fairly
restrictive like even a fairly
restrictive version of this is already
somewhat useful just as basically
something that's you know in the same
way that netlogo is not that general but
still there's a whole big class of
models that people use it to play around
with
you know it's worth just supporting
some of those
okay so let's understand what we would
need to support those i mean basically
in
every agent so we have a
a the state of the system
reporting in progress basically
with each agent having a certain state
an unordered list of agents probably
do you agree with that statement
i i agree probably yeah
with each agent
um having a certain state
okay and for example this state here
is a pretty reasonable kind of state for
it to have so some of that state
some parts of the state
are fixed
can vary
but i don't see any particular reason to
distinguish those two things just as
in the end body case the velocity and
momentum vary but typically the mass
does not vary
does that does that make sense but then
now what's interesting about the ambody
case a non-trivial is that i think in a
lot of these agent-based things it's
just you do a time step the the boyd's
the ants whatever look around they do
their thing then they go to the next
time step and then body simulation
that's been made more sophisticated
because the time steps are adaptive and
all kinds of things like this
um
it would be very cool to support some
kind of adaptive time step thing with at
least some models but yeah
i'm not sure how i mean it definitely
would require the person implementing
the model to do a bit more work but i'm
not sure how much more work well it may
be that if we correctly parameterize the
models that we can figure out for them
what kind of adaptation is possible i
mean it may depend on look the fact is
if you know okay so i suspect the
following is true assume
we can compile
the function that
that implements
what each agent does
okay so i'm going to make the the
following outrageous claim
if we can do things like automatic
differentiation on that function we can
figure out if we can do numerical
analysis well but hold on i mean that's
if it's a function like you know the end
body function or something like that but
suppose it's you know i don't know
suppose it's something where
um every
you know at every step that has a you
know
10 chance of picking a new target
position or god knows what something
like that
okay then how are you going to implement
that well that's an interesting one
because that particular one a 10 chance
that has to go from a discrete
random process to a continuous random
process maybe roger can say something
about that but then what what what is
the story of automatic differentiation
and the presence of randomness roger
[Music]
well i mean any numeric procedure
there's
yeah well
i don't think i can answer that just
that flexibly after you ask it
i think for for a particular function
it's clear what it does a particular
program
no but if you feed okay so here's the
way to think about this think about
stochastic calculus okay yeah but i
don't think right
i mean algorithmic differentiation cares
if some variables are random or not it
just differentiates it doesn't
the question is what's valid i mean
what's what makes it sort of useful
no and in terms of doing it it's not a
problem
but my point is let's say you have one
of your control systems things and by
the way control systems is another area
of um you know all the control systems
functionality
is another area
um
and it will be very nice as we think
about these agent-based models just
imagine you could put you know a pid
controller on your aunt or something
is that a reasonable thing what would
that look like roger if let's say that
the individual agents were responding
according to a control system
well you sort of do that with drone when
you have big clusters of drones
and
and and so they're
they're
the sort of things that you call like
distributed control systems so if you
want to control a whole
like a flock of drones kind of like in
the last olympics or something
you wanna you know there's individual
control for each one drone which it then
breaks down to even more individual
control for the individual motors and
stuff
right but then there's basically control
for the whole flock to behave
and so that's kind of what
um you know what's being worked on how
do you control that whole flock as one
object basically
right but what i'm asking but the
individual ones that they might only
care about distances to their neighbors
for instance that's to think roughly
speaking how that works
okay but so it is in fact okay so let's
let's ask at the level of our software
stack
you know we have a control systems a
whole bunch of control systems
functionality yeah if we wanted to
insert that okay so so in a rough
approximation okay the rough work role
approximate workflow for agent-based
models
um
would be
uh you know
uh we have a global state
at each step
each agent
each agent
each agent's function
ingests the global ingest some aspects
of the global state some typically
relative aspects of the global state
and resets its and resets its state
correct
probably i mean
probably in the most general case you
just want it so that each agent takes
its state and
some you know some global state i mean
maybe it's just that you know it takes
its state and then the states of all the
other agents
although i suspect that a very common
function will be the nearest neighbor
agents or something sure but right i
mean i think that i think the most
general case would probably be that it
takes the global state and then there
are a whole bunch of other like like let
me give you some examples right even
with voids right which is one
pretty simple model i've seen boyds
where it's you find all the neighbors
within a radius where you find the n
nearest neighbors you know where you
have some sort of adaptive thing where
you know you find the end nearest
neighbors but you know you you are sort
of sticky so if one of them goes a bit
further away then you keep looking at it
stuff like this you know i don't think
we'll be able to parametrize all of
those
all right fine although although it
might be that we end up with some kind
of special function that's useful for
those kinds of things but you think it's
a nearest
but might
you know include weird stickiness and
things weird historical stickiness well
or or any other things like i mean i
don't know if you look at you know if
you look at some of the more
like if you just think of boys it seems
pretty clear-cut but some of these
models they don't even the spatial
aspect isn't as important and stuff like
that and it
it breaks down a lot or maybe where they
just have a fixed set of five neighbors
they keep the entire time so i don't
know i think that
i mean probably you can have some spec
that looks like the spec for nearest
which accepts you know you could say all
and that would do all of them you give
it a number and you give it a radius but
okay so what we think is roughly there's
an agent function which gets the current
state of this agent and the global state
and returns new agent state
right
so this is also a global function like
like you know if there's some
well actually because sometimes there's
stuff like there's state in the
background like maybe it's a bunch of
agents walking around in a field and
there's properties of the field
so you might also want to have
some like
there's there's the agent state then
there's the other agents like the
neighboring agent state and then there's
the global like background state okay
might also want to have a function which
updates the global background state
every step
okay so hold on a second so it might
want to distinguish
a list of agent states
from a global background state
i suspect that that's going to want to
be hierarchical
[Music]
rather than just saying that there's
agents and there's a background
i mean why couldn't there be super
agents there are you know there are
little creatures that live inside bigger
creatures and things like this
i mean because those like i think
there's a there's a fundamental
distinction between like
you know like yes you could implement
the global background as like having a
special agent you know agent number 12
is the background or something like that
but it'll just be a total pain
and it's it's such a common idiot okay
all right all right okay so fair enough
so that's a okay but let's go
then assume we have something like this
okay so then what would boyd's roughly
look like what would the agent function
for boy i mean oh no i was going to say
something what do boyds do i mean i've
seen pictures of them what but what do
they actually do
they go around in flocks
they so they they the goal is to create
a flock or something
yeah right so here for example let's do
an example i don't know this is the 3d
one whether this is particularly useful
but i'm sure if we play this
absolutely nothing happens there must be
a 2d voids thing here
um
they flock around like birds or like
fish
okay
so so there i can i can explain where
you're finding this i mean there are
three rules for boyd's there's
the cohesion where basically the voids
will you know a boy will try and move
toward the center of mass of all the
voids it sees
there's separation which is if it's
really close to another boy it'll move
away from it
and there's alignment which is it tries
to you know point in the same direction
as the void that it can see
say that last one
so the alignment is basically that they
they try and point in the same direction
as the other boards around them okay
okay so there they are roger
okay world size starting
and they basically have those three
rules that you said
yeah and that's it
okay
and then you can vary the strength
between them that's probably what the
bro just do here
yes yeah you can vary the strength then
you can vary how what other boys each
boy can see because normally they can
see within some radius they can see the
top three nearest or closer okay
right so here the number of boyds is too
small and the the radius is too big so
they can all be in one big flock but if
the radius is smaller compared to the
number of boys then take the visibility
radius then then they'll it'll do
funkier stuff
somebody needs to fix this bug
this stuff has actually been i mean i
think that that was introduced as a toy
problem in the 80s right 1980s or
something like that the boyd business
i was introduced by a chap called craig
reynolds who was doing them for movies
was it the 1980s or yes
okay but in modern times
this stuff has become
you know quite studied
you know for real industrial things like
you want one operator to control
multiple drones
by the way i bet this is a change in the
numerical evaluator
for um uh
sorry i'm just this is irrelevant but i
we might as well report the bug
um
uh somebody i think arctan of zero zero
is just kind of ambiguous well normally
when there's a boy that's off on its own
and so the center of mass of the it's
trying to figure out the angle it needs
to point that in order to point at the
center of mass of its neighbors
right you know it's zero anyway okay
sorry roger you were saying i'm saying
that that that sort of related problems
have been very seriously studied by
roboticists and others you know control
people
and you know so for instance you want
one you want basically one pilot to
control a whole group of drones
for instance
um
i think there's a huge boyd's industry
by the way i mean i don't think this is
a this is not a corner case so it's not
a i mean this seems like a toy to me to
illustrate something
but but i'm just saying it's it's also
you know actually useful
well i think there's a whole world of i
mean
i think you're you're kind of right but
there's this whole world i mean
particularly instead of the complex
systems
you know orbit there there are endless
agent-based models like this that yes
are basically toys but people do spend a
whole lot of time you know studying
their behavior right because but the
goal there is it's some kind of insight
right it's enough to do this and you get
the phenol you know right but roger what
you're pointing out is that there's an
industrial use of these things like yeah
yeah yeah and it's intel's favorite you
know drone configuration you know uh uh
you know firework display type thing yes
and
um
[Music]
i'm trying to remember there are other
related things but drones are so very
visible today but but they're these
things where you can't necessarily
communicate so well with everything that
you need to control like
i don't know power systems distributed
power systems and things like that
right
right so okay so some of it is very you
know has gotten a lot of attention
and is actually
um seriously used
we're getting indeed right
um
okay we have various comments on the
live stream i was just exchanged mail
with craig reynolds recently he's mostly
working on camouflage models these days
um
the uh
and actually
uh
i know christopher had done some stuff
on camouflage models too and somebody
should send
said things okay look at this this is
craig's original page
about boyds
and those looks like cray computers
there yeah
what's that what was it in the 80s was
that roughly the right yes yes yes yes
86 he says
okay cool
and it was used first for some batman
movie as i recall
right
um
okay
so anyway so that's an example of a
model
um and uh
being pointed to one other thing yeah
good yes i mean by the way if you want
to see examples of other things i mean
just just to get a sense of breadth
because i think that right now we're
talking about is very void focused
i just sent in the the chat a link to
the like netlogo
you know example models page
so i don't know if you pick something
random you'll probably see some weird
model that looks fairly different from
boyds
i think some of these aren't really
agent-based but
they seem similar
well if you do
you put the moths in different places
but
um do you do one there's one that i like
i i've looked at many of these but
there's one called i think roads or
something
but do they all have a spatial thing to
them i mean
no kind of
maybe these
so some of these turn into cellular
automata some of them are actually
actually our cellular automata but the
whole point is to go away from cellular
automata to something where
you are
you know okay so so the simple-minded
way of doing this is it's kind of like
you know something like a mobile
automaton or a touring machine or a 2d
turing machine is picking up a global
state but the whole point here is that
there tend to be interactions between
agents
but christopher what was the one you
were suggesting
well the one i was suggesting is called
roads just because i know it has
background state although it looked like
that termites one also had some sort of
background
global state
there's also i've never wrote this but
but you could write your sort of robot
to do
to to to have tournaments between robots
they were you know so each robot was an
agent and you got to fight another agent
as opposed to flocking like we see here
yeah and then you can do the genetic
programming thing of you know there are
genetically
okay yeah
dining philosophers is that
oh that's the one where they each want
each other's utensils
indeed but is that
that one is one where the timing matters
yeah
right
right i mean but now there's also some
stuff like this where i imagine that you
know
right it's probably more natural just to
write that from scratch than it is to
use some agent-based modeling framework
i agree especially because that's one
that specifically bites into
the whole
you know synchronization issue
i mean i'm sure something like this
might be a reasonable house looks like
an eaten model but my guess that's just
an eden model
um
yeah
i mean
there's another nearby thing which i am
not
it could be this but i don't think it is
the same
which is sort of discrete event
simulation
um
yes
which sort of fits the queuing network
stuff that i was talking about elevator
systems things like that which you could
argue that there are agents going into
elevators and picking floors and stuff
like traffic systems
um i don't know i think it's a corner of
this i mean look another thing that's
very directly
so aggregation models
are a
see that one is different because that
one is sequential
that one is sequentialized
you know like the eden model remember
that guy
where you basically let me see i can
find one where is eden
um
this is if i was a complex systems guy i
would know all these right because it's
i recognize that there's nothing
you would actually i'm not sure they
even talk about this one but okay but
this one is is you've got a cluster
and you
randomly
at every step you randomly pick a a
point on the boundary of a cluster and
add a new a new cell
okay
okay
and then it goes to this disk and it
converts
it it well it almost a disk it actually
doesn't turn out to be exactly a disk
on on a
on a standard square grid and you can
have slightly more elaborate rules you
can also do diffusion limited
aggregation where instead of just adding
um or instead of just adding this at the
outer boundary
uh you know just picking a place you
insist that the thing has to follow a
random walk from infinity to get there
so that means that if there's a you know
that it's much less likely to get into a
shielded region so to speak into into a
bay than to get into onto a promontory
and so it has a habit of um uh
the um
um
okay
so i mean so this case is interesting
because it is sequentialized that is
you're adding one
one
you know one element at a time which is
a little different i suspect in these
agent-based models which are quite
parallel and my guess is that we will
wind up with a different function that
does essentially the aggregation type
thing
right i mean i think that the basic like
right i mean there's a very big set i
mean if we look at for example again the
net logo models there's a huge class of
things they do a lot of them are best
done from scratch and i think that you
know if we want to have some agent-based
modeling function it should really only
try and get the ones that you know right
now are very easy to do and say net logo
but not very easy to do mathematica
right
right well so okay so fine so that
that's so that's our target
to begin with although i do think the
aggregation model thing might actually
be easier i mean so that would be basic
boy we've already got a thing called
aggregation layer but let's imagine we
have aggregation model
and then it's basically
you have to define its it's um uh well
you have the initial state which is a
grid of some kind
and you have the um
uh
well
i think this one is really from scratch
like i'd be shocked if there was really
much i mean this is a function like
cellular automata although it's probably
more you know stochastic
but i i don't think this will be a very
general function
right but look this is this is what it
look no i i
well probably you're right but it looks
at a neighborhood
so they're really cases you know
look at a local neighborhood
um
and uh
well basically it's it's
what the heck is it it's it's
yeah it really depends on things like
surfaces you know find a local
neighborhood
with a particular form
find a local neighborhood with a
particular form
and
do something to it
so i mean that that would be things like
a totalistic rule would just say
yeah i mean so i think what this is is
more like a sequentialized cellular
automaton where you're just looking at a
randomized sequentialized cellular
automaton
all right so this is maybe irrelevant
i mean but in terms of the
yeah go ahead
well i mean i was just going to say in
terms of the the agent rates i mean
but i think the things that we probably
want to focus on more are again things
like you know boyds are like those you
know termites or whatever other random
models were there where it's sort of
like
i don't know i mean i think they have
constructs like okay you want to know
uh okay if the background is you know a
grid which i don't know maybe it isn't
always but but you know if the
background is a good what square am i on
or what's the you know what color is the
square i'm on or you might want to do
something like point toward this other
agent or point toward this position and
then you know move forward this much i
mean i don't know if we want to have
that much you know
turtles
i think these are the kinds of
primitives that are probably right okay
let's so let's go back down here so
we're basically going to go
you know turtle-like agents
so they typically have
a
you know they might have
a position and direction
how common is that
i don't know i mean i think
so one of the problems is that at least
a lot of the things that you know at
least that i've seen in sort of the
complex systems world you know they're
very influenced by the tools in the
sense that you know
there's a certain tendency to you know
have things running around on a 2d grid
you know with a colored background or
whatever because basically that's what
netlogo supports
um so i think we you know we should be
more general but right that's a
yeah in terms of existing stuff that's
very common
well so the point is one question is
does velocity
you know
is there an x and an x dot which there
is in this case
because the velocity implies something
about the position
in other words is is um do the to the
parameters
have intrinsic interdependence
eg
velocity and position
i mean maybe one one more general
question is just that it seems like we
probably should support the most general
case where you know
you don't necessarily have a direction
you might not even necessarily have a
position
um
but but but then it would be nice if
then we have special stuff or if you do
happen to have a position
all right so what's the relationship
between nest list
and everything we're talking about to
what extent is agent function just
a
nest list i mean it is a specialization
i think of nest list on the global state
i claim
well where global state is both the
background state and all the agent
states or something
right and i mean init state
and some number of steps that will be a
most minimal version without adaptive
time stepping without any of those kinds
of things but also has one important
feature that's a mess which is that it's
not
going through and saying
which agent you are so to speak it's
it's just
it doesn't distinguish your local state
it doesn't have that there's another
loop here which is basically saying
um
uh
you know agent function
um
is mapped on to
well the whatever the
global state sub
me
so to speak
and
what is going on here so but basically
this is somehow
the in the if the global state is a list
of of of associations representing let's
imagine that the basic data structure is
a list of associations representing the
states of agents
i mean
and do you think that's a reasonable
thing to do
yes except that i think that there
probably does need to be a background
some sort of other
information
place
well it's a bit like a sparse array then
i mean should it be like a sparse array
or should this thing here
have a wrapper
that represents you know where it says
um agents and then it says background
why i don't know what you mean by by
sparseray i mean i i just mean that you
know you have the states of all the
agents and then you also need the states
for you know the stage on which the
agents are moving
and any other global metadata that all
the agents need access to
all right
well
so i mean okay so my question is in
terms of data structure is the right
thing a list of agents states and a
background an association or should it
work differently
i mean that that seems reasonable i
guess yeah
um but then each
so i mean this function
i'm just not sure it's worth doing it
this way because
well no i mean in the end
the output is going to be as a function
of time the output of this function of
the nest list
you know
agent based nest list
or agent based i mean what we have for
end body simulation is we have the
simulation function right
or we have something which is the output
of the simulation
making sense is that what you imagine
that this you know so if you write
basically if you provide state update
functions
that simulation function can run the
full simulation
and
maybe
provide some
some global final state you know some
aggregate you know something that you
accumulate along the way
something that tells you how it evolved
yes exactly no i think that's right
because because it doesn't seem sensible
to store
you know to just say explicitly we're
going to have a list of states here
maybe you can get that out as a property
of you know i mean basically this
becomes agent-based simulation
of blah blah blah blah blah
and you can say here if you want to you
can say final state or you can say
something else
i think that's what we're doing in the
in the case of end body simulation right
now
well i think the main motivation for
doing that with them body simulation
which i don't know maybe it turns out
we'll support this here but i think the
main reason is because it's basically
returning some kind of interpolating
function
yes
but but if you really have clear defined
clearly defined steps
yeah i guess you can do the same thing
i'm just imagining you know one case
that that might come up i know like
like in i don't know 10 years ago or
something when i was playing with boyd's
i had these things where like um it was
a problem if you uh
you know you didn't want to store all
the time steps because there'd be way
too many like eat up all your memory so
you'd want to do something like store
every 100th time step yes i just i'd
worry about you know having some big
object
that you know you run it and then this
object is massive and then you're
supposed to query that you i think you
want to have some kinds of
you know you want to be able to request
only certain things be stored even when
you make the object okay so let's
compare that with nd solvent and table
but sometimes like for discrete event
for instance simulation which is also i
mean one could argue is in some form of
agent-based but
um
one of the things that there's usually
something that is the goal with the
simulation something that you want to
accumulate
you know the distribution of this or
that
then you might even want to optimize it
and so they have
you know that they're sort of things
that promote that with that workflow
like something that reduces the variance
for instance so you get the value more
quickly
that that you're kind of looking right
just stimulus like with probabilistic
programming you want to be able to get
the distribution
without i mean you know one way to get
so i mean one objective
compute probability distributions
which we've which after all we've done
you know
where you could you know eg monte carlo
but that isn't the best way to do it
usually
but there may be better ways
yeah
and and i agree that that's a that's a
thing you might want to do independent
of and particularly you might want to do
that if there is randomness
that's why i'm thinking it's useful to
think about sort of what is the workflow
and what's the goal because you know
like interpolating function
that we deliver from numerical
simulation
it makes
it makes all the workflows that work for
other functions like special functions
also work for numerical simulation
that's one of the things that that does
it plugs in so all the same workflows
apply
okay well fine so then the question here
is
what okay
so what are the relevant workflows
you know what are all the things and i
think that we're
for all these other simulation or or
modeling areas we're going back and
answered or asking the question why
again
you know because we we expanding the
workflows and and we come to a little
bit different conclusions
okay so one one thing would be and by
the way this in the wolfram model
simulation
stuff we have exactly the same issues
over again i mean we can we can add that
to our list up here
um
uh
in fact if we look at that very function
we can see
um
[Music]
yeah there's probably a whole set of
models also that run on on you know
graphs as opposed to run on you know
space oh that's a good point that's a
good point that's a good point
right so see that that's not hard to
implement if you have the background
if you have this background data the
background data could just be the
network and then yeah what is the base
space
is the question but but what like what
is is your goal like in animation it's
the gold graphics
right right right i think that the
really i think the ultimate goal is you
just want to know you know what you want
to know the output of nest list
basically just what was the sequence of
states
but you know it might be nice if we have
nice graphics in certain cases you know
if if for example you know all of the
the agents have a position
specific position argument then maybe we
can have a little graphic for it i don't
know but well but here's a here's an
example this is or is it to compute some
statistics some some you know do that do
does agent in fact compute something
right so i mean it might be generate
final state eg to plot it
it might be
um
show the paths
of a few
a few uh
you know
chosen agents through time
it might be find the
uh
distribution of
of densities of agents
in a given region let's
say let's see i think for for stuff like
that you know if you want to do
statistics on the whole time series you
know that's very easy to do just from
scratch right if you're just given here
all the states it's easy to just pull
out all the positions and i know but if
that's the right way to do it but if if
we had some ability to do you know some
kind of generalized i mean this is sort
of important sampling
in well multi-way graphs in our modern
way of thinking about it but i mean you
know something like probabilistic
programming where you're ending up doing
important sampling and the paths of all
possible program you know
or possible program parts you might do a
hell of a lot better than just saying
generate the giant you know
every time step every
branch so to speak
thing
right in other words in other words
there's a lot more information if you
look at to put it in physics terms the
multi-way graph right where you're
looking at the branching you say if i
take this probabilistic variable to this
value at this step versus this value
i've shared a lot of other state
right whereas if i just do pure monte
carlo and i've got every state generated
afresh i've got huge amounts more data
to get the same amount of information
that made sense
maybe that didn't make sense
um
but
but okay so i mean
what other things i mean so basically
what we want is some kind of you know
agent-based model agent-based simulation
function or something or something like
that
that we can query various features of
and
presumably when we do the simulation we
want to be able to give a
a a time stepping information like the
boyd's thing where you say do 100 steps
between everyone that's stored
presumably
question
in
in the usual way this is done
it is the case that
the sort of distributed computing aspect
is done in a trivial way that is you
have a single time step and it's like
every boy look at every every agent look
at all the other agents and see what to
do
synchronously so to speak it's not
ripple through the agents
you know updating one first then the
next but
depending on in other words it's it's
it's i believe in signal processing that
would be the difference between finite
impulse response and infinite impulse
response
did that well actually i was i was going
to bring that one up earlier because for
example
i think it varies like for example with
voids you usually do you know everyone
moves at once
but for uh for example with the traffic
modeling stuff that you know like
solutions a little while ago that was
not like that that was uh that was one
one car moves first then the next and
the next
that's interesting
i mean because the thing is like with
with with the cars you have requirements
like if one person if one car moves one
way you have to make sure the next car
doesn't move into it so there's actually
it's not local the model is not local
right
well what about i think that's why
doesn't the same thing happen with birds
well do they don't care as much if they
crash into each other i mean i think you
just don't really care as much because
it's not discreet and you have
continuous space usually but but i mean
i think that's something where they're
probably worth having an auction or
something where you can kind of by the
way that is the exact same thing that
we're running into in this
multi-computation business about
evaluation funds
that's the same story of evaluation
fronts
versus tree traversal order they're all
the same
you know same story i think
i mean this is this is essentially
a is it breadth first is it depth first
what is it
well it's much simpler though because i
think that
i mean okay maybe maybe this isn't i
i've never seen a model like this and i
haven't seen that many but i've never
seen a model like this where you run you
know one agent twice before you run
another agent
right like i mean i think that
well okay so one example is in end body
simulation
a random thing that's become very famous
that i suggested to some people at lunch
and sometime in the 1980s that some that
some you know n log n algorithm for
doing end body simulation where you
basically
look at where you clump things together
and consider
i mean i guess that's a little different
where you where you consider
you know where you have hierarchicalized
the the structure of the simulation
i mean that's hot right
yes right yes
i think that's probably too custom like
i think that's something that
yeah i mean
the actual implementation like the
barnes-hunt algorithm is sufficiently
i don't think that that would be
possible to do that in sort of a
in in a framework like this
but i think that what it is it's it's
hierarchical that general idea
of
i mean okay it probably depends on the
fact that it's gravity which is a long
way it does a lot i mean i can i can i
can tell you basically i mean it works
by you construct a quad tree
and then you know
you you basically traverse down the quad
tree
uh and you know for each sort of you
know points for each self-gravitating
point it looks at the it goes down the
quad tree on all the different branches
and it will stop going down once
you know either it reaches a single
point or once the sort of square of that
quad tree is you know
the size the square divided by the
distance away is less than some number
right which one is it yeah the basic
point is do you represent the complete
state
or do you represent it as a quad tree
but see i don't really know of any other
like
the quad tree that that whole setup
seems i agree it's mostly long-range
forces it's probably mostly relevant for
long-range forces but the quad tree is
the complete state it's just sort of
organized for
fast search
exactly but it's organized so that many
effects don't require you to go to the
bottom of the quad tree i mean it's
similar to wavelet type stuff where many
things you compute don't require you to
go down to the individual bits
this is only specific to these n squared
things anyway right because
right i mean because if you're running
something like boyd's voids is not
squared because there's a you know they
have a limited visibility radius
and so
something like this i don't think really
makes any sense fair enough okay
probably too specific
um
okay a comment i see there are multiple
comments on our live stream all kinds of
interesting things here including swarms
of robot vacuum cleaners
um
yes
mixing voids with neural nets to evolve
a battle boyd
yes people have done that
um
uh
oh yeah stove is commenting on
aggregation models where there's a
chance to detach as well
that's interesting
yes we haven't thought about that
um
uh
okay uh
michael here is saying need a
generalized framework for agent-based
simulation and machine learning where
internal states are abstracted like a
gradient policy optimize
roger can you unpack that
um
no i don't know what that means
i mean i i know those words i just i do
too but there's some that sounds like
it's um
well it's but it's up i mean the main
issue is
okay so one point is okay look
i mean things in the loop
that might be interesting
our control systems framework
machine learning
you know system modeler stuff
what else might be interesting to have
in the loop so to speak for an
agent-based model
visualization stuff
no but i'm saying in the loop as part of
the action of the agents
i mean like you can imagine the action
of the agent is a pid controller or the
action of the agent is a neural net
sure okay sure i mean certainly there
are a bunch of functions that are
probably very common like nearest maybe
but
yes yeah
right but i mean many of these so again
i was asking roger for control systems
yeah okay is it the case like with
machine learning i can kind of imagine
what it would look like it would say
predict
you know
blah blah blah blah blah
current state
would return what to do
well i i mean i don't think you probably
want to use a predictor function that
you'd use in each agent but actually
this does raise the question of um
this would definitely need to interact
with reinforcement learning stuff
yes that's quite true
i don't really i haven't really learned
use the reinforcement function
reinforcement learning functions enough
to know whether or not that's
reinforcement learning is a mess and as
roger keeps on emphasizing it's the same
story as
control systems that's optimal control
yeah
right i mean for example if the way
again i don't really know those
functions work right now um but you know
if those functions worked in some way
where it's like oh you have your you
know
reinforcement learning object and then
you can call some function in each agent
and add this object then that would
probably be not too hard but if you need
to
you know
my impression is that's not how it works
it's more of a uh
you have to give it a
like but but all controllers
you know i mean except for the very
simplest ones they have their own
state too
um they have
they have sort of the state on the
system they control and they have just
their own state and given those two
states they can they compute what to do
so to speak their action
okay so that's the basic
what what what is our
what is this i mean this is
this is an example based on an external
thing but there is usually the example
in a in the first in the control theory
101 this is usually the first example
shown
right
but the point is that agent-based models
you know that's a that's an external
reinforcement learning environment i
think agent-based models would be
another you know environment in which
you want to agent-based
agent-based f reinforcement learning but
i think it's
these reinforcement learning
environments my impressions they're much
more one-off
they're a horrible mess i mean we've
tried to do the same meta-modeling thing
for those and it's super you know this
is the thing we learn
in doing this design over and over again
every time the setup every time the
minimal example of something is
complicated the level of usage is
dramatically reduced and so i think
that's i think that this is a like the
the problem with those reinforcement
learning environments is that people
want to do something like i want to do
reinforcement learning in you know super
mario or something like that
right and so that's of course
the environment is is very complicated
but i think that
you could definitely imagine having much
simpler examples where you have you know
where your boys are learning to you know
avoid the predator voids and stuff like
that
yes
yeah well that might help i mean that
might be a case where we could it might
help us to understand how to do
reinforcement because
you know what we have right now i don't
even know why that isn't what so can you
can you only do reinforcement learning
right now in one of these
open no no no no you can you can do it
in um where is i don't understand where
where is the active classify
active classification why isn't that
listed
and anywhere in that neural net maybe
that's that was neural network layers
but oh it was oh that was why it wasn't
listed
okay so this is an example of the kind
of thing we're dealing with right this
is a mess
this is a mess it's one of those
functions that has
okay so roger optimal control what's the
function for that
we don't have it i mean we have it in
more specialized cases but i think the
promise of reinforcement learning it
because it's it it
it becomes super complicated in the
general case
so
we have more specialized cases like lq
regulator and things like that but in
the general case
it optimal control has a cursive
dimensionality so you can't really do it
in practice so you need to approximate
it and what reinforcement learning kind
of gives us is a means of approximation
so i think it it's it's a it's sort of
promising in that sense
okay so what the heck is this i mean
this is the place where i just
completely lose it because like what
goes in what comes out this is a very
complicated setup
and at least when represented in terms
of functions with arguments and things
well it's dynamic that's the problem the
function is not dynamic notice
notice that we've got the same problem
over here
you know our agents want to dynamically
respond to their environment
yeah yes but but
well i mean extra comes out there is the
state of the system
okay okay
that that you know this in the first
case there i know the state of the
system and the only thing i'm gonna do
is to basically dot that state with
something to decide how i'm gonna
you know affect the system
okay but coming back to what we were
talking about before
the fundamental structure is there is a
function it is applied okay so just a
minute the sort of fundamental
agent-based structure
is there is a micro step function
which basically does
given an instantaneous state
compute the next one
then there is presumably a a
uh evolution representation function
that might aggregate many micro steps
for everything it stores
so there's a fair
characterization and then out of that we
can extract and so whoops i'm in trouble
i get to go
okay
sorry
so
maybe the model is to be more like you
know i don't know their functions like
cellular automatar i think turing
machine now too where it takes a big
association and basically you know there
are different ways of specifying things
and you know or not specifying things
and it will you know so one example of
where i think that would be useful is
you know we talked about earlier
you could your your you know your step
function
it might uh it might be able to accept
like the delta t like how long was this
time step if it's doing adaptive
sampling although i'm not sure exactly
how that would work
you know or maybe it you know or maybe
it just always assumes it's you know
time you know the steps are all the same
size so you could have two different
keys you know for representing that look
i don't understand why at the lowest
level you know boyd's could be an end
body simulation i mean the birds could
be falling out of the sky and parabolas
and things
so to speak
in principle one could wrap and body
simulation as the steps
sure i mean i i guess that
i mean are you are you making a
statement about adaptive sampling or no
i i don't know what i yes i'm making a
statement that that really you know okay
we could have
end body simulation so i think one of
the big differences between anabolic
simulation and this is that end body
simulation no matter what you put into
it it always can go into nd solve
right which can do adaptive sampling it
can do you know it's differentiable et
cetera well except for whenever
the point is that the general stuff you
have in these agent-based models is like
so far away from something you put into
nd solve
well no not all of them which is i mean
why i'm saying it might be worth
basically having you know if you set up
the input in a certain way it'll try and
convert it into some nice nd solving
with fancy adaptive sampling and so on
right you know there's also has to be
you know a simpler fallback case which
is probably most models
i agree doesn't do that i agree i agree
i agree i mean the
the thing is i mean
system modeler is a good example of
where you might think you can't actually
do things with differential equations
but actually even with 50 000
differential equations
you can actually do stuff
right i mean i think the point is though
is that you have to
you know if you want for example to
support adaptive sampling you need to
provide more
you know you need to provide more so i
think i think that
in the simplest cases i like basically
you need to be able to
specify hey i'm going to give you a
function that can take all these special
parameters and as a gift for me
providing such a fancy function you'll
give me automatic adaptive sampling etc
yes fair point fair point
i mean
how
yes i see okay so so then
you know
adaptive sampling
if you specify very particular functions
if you specify particular update
update functions in a particular way
i guess yeah
like you're suggesting in the cellular
automaton case you can either give an
arbitrary boolean function or you can
give something which has been
parametrized where it knows a lot more
but i want to come back to the original
question of you know
your
you know the original thing that you
might do is you might have um uh
something where you say
agent-based model for example
or agent-based simula simul well it
would be enbodies simulation is better
right agent-based simulation it's not a
model it's a simulation of the model
yeah right exactly
um
and so this should be modeled on
and body simulation probably
um
and and body simulation
basically takes okay so it has it has
the law
which is otherwise known as the rule and
it has a bunch of states of the bodies
right it's actually very directly
analogous
right and actually this is a nice
feature because the bodies can have
names here
right
so
right it either has a list of bodies or
it has named
you know the bird called fred and the
bird called
jemima or whatever
um
i think that was the name of puddle duck
but that may have been in a very ancient
part of history
um the uh
anyway
so this is this is the basic structure
then and then what should be returned
it should look very much like this i
would think
does that seem correct no i mean i think
i think that seems good i mean i think
that
i think that part is pretty
clear
the harder part is i think that there
are i mean the basic question is what is
the actual interface of what things do
you need to provide in order to specify
the model but by the way by the way even
this isn't totally clear so i mean a
typical
eg
you know ants in a field or something or
you know in a field um the the states
would be
you know position arrow whatever so it's
going to look something like this it's
going to be position arrow
i mean just to be explicit about what
will happen it'll look like this and
we'll have a giant list of position
arrow blah
position arrow blah
okay and again probably also you need to
specify the background
yes i understand optionally yeah right
okay all right okay so then then it
would be agent-based model
of of um uh agent function
init
steps
and then it's some kind of
but the background can get updated as
well can't it
yes
right i mean i think you need the
background also you need like a global
you need some function like this is i
mean probably for the rule
right for the agent function you're
probably not getting the aging function
in the simplest case the first usage
line it probably is agent function but
for all the other ones it's probably a
big association with
here's the initial you know here's maybe
the initial background state or here's
the background update function and you
know
etc right okay so what you're what
you're suggesting is that a net
normally would be
uh either would be
could be either just a regular init or
it could be
agent states
and then it's a list of agent states
background state or global state
i mean you could maybe even imagine well
this is probably a bad idea
you could maybe imagine a uh you know
making it super general where you'd have
an association with agents and you have
an association where you'd say agents
arrow this and then maybe background
error or that and then you know in the
in the function like in the in the the
rule part in that association maybe you
could just say
i don't know you'd say something like
functions arrow and then you'd say agent
arrow this background there or that i
mean the point being just that in
addition to agents and background you
could have arbitrary keys but i don't
know how useful that is yes yes yes
possibility of arbitrary keys in
addition to
just agent state
and background
okay but but so roughly
i mean one thing i'm thinking about is
once you've got this okay what is the
minimal piece of code to make a picture
and essentially what you've got to do is
you've got to say
uh i mean it's a little bit of a mess
right because the list of these are i
mean you would say
you know hash position slash at
well i think probably the most minimal i
mean honestly if all the agents have a
position parameter and they're all the
same dimension and so on i mean i think
i'd imagine that the
whatever it's called agent-based
simulation output or something should
probably just show it
yeah okay fair enough okay so then then
basic visualization
could just be
you know a
property
of um
of agent based simulation data
which would be the analogous thing to
end body simulation
and presumably you'd also yeah i mean
you could ask for stuff probably like
the the video of it like the animated
image or you could ask for the
yeah
video
that's nice by the way the fact that we
have video now and you could just
straight ask for that
that's a pretty nifty thing
arguably we should have that for embody
simulations well that's a good idea
um
to uh
i don't think we have anybody um
uh let me make that suggestion to shoddy
um
i wonder whether there are other
functions like that that should have a
direct video
that's a new meaning for direct to video
um
a direct to video function so to speak
uh
anyway
okay so that that that's for some
visualization
or one could have um
you know final
final
state
final state well that there will be
other final state final state plot
those kinds of things
i suspect we're going to need a special
function called agent
agent-based simulation plot or something
because i think it's going to have lots
of options
like how to
how to render this particular attribute
you know in color et cetera et cetera et
cetera
and whether to make a bubble chart where
the where the you know
uh the the the alpha bird is bigger or
something those kinds of things
um maybe that's too specialized
um we should probably wrap up soon for
now but i think we're off and running on
the quite interesting direction here i
mean this looks to me like it's
something can be done it's just a
question of making sure that the um
uh
i mean and and then probably will
actually want
um
you know
special functions
and i wonder whether we actually want
something where we say agent based model
voids
comma
some parameters
i mean we could do that if that's if it
turns out you know just like axiomatic
theory you can type in the axiom system
every time but it's a nuisance
and if there are you know if there are a
limited set of
of these kinds of models that we have to
enumerate that might be a good way to do
it what do you think
yeah i mean i think
no reason not to yeah
i mean but is there a discrete set it
seems like there is it seems like
there's voids and termites and this and
that and the other there's a limited
number of these things that are i mean
i'm not sure how many really celebrity
ones there are like voids
i mean some level if there are only two
that's still okay i mean it kind of
makes it easier at some level yeah well
it's still useful and i mean rather than
having a function specifically for that
um
okay let's just look at a few comments
on our live stream and then we should
wrap up soon
um
okay ali is saying the agent-based model
can extend to computation done on meshes
where a vertex in its neighborhood are
important and abstract properties can be
defined
oh that's a good that's a good base
space question right so that this is a
good point base
spaces okay what are some reasonable
base spaces
a grid
or array
that's one kind of base space a graph is
another kind of base space well in
addition to grid array i mean there's
also continuous like euclidean space
which is maybe different from discrete
yes i agree on a grid yeah right you put
in space
i mean just to be exotic we'll also you
know
non-euclidean space spheres etc
spears are reasonable but yeah
hyperbolic voids it would be interesting
maybe not
super necessary it's not a v1
feature but meshes probably is a real
thing
certainly a base space with a region
is is highly relevant oh yeah here's
another issue it's boundaries
right if you have some weirdly shaped
boundary region yeah yeah i mean this is
why
i mean this is why i think it's worth
having some
you know
right i mean if we're imagining a
sort of a spatial agent-based model like
boyd's and you want to to write it in
such a way that
you know
well also there's stuff like so okay you
want to write in such a way that for
example boundary conditions are
respected so you can specify that this
one's on a taurus this one's on a sphere
and maybe even so that you know they
stay within some weirdly shaped region i
think you need to have other hooks in
terms of moving them around and stuff
like that
or maybe you don't maybe you just
provide their update their positions as
normal and you know based on some
options in the you know uh when you call
the simulation function it will sort of
alter the positions to you know make
them go around the taurus or whatever
look we've got incredibly elaborate
boundary specifications for pdes
we should just use them here
sure could be possible to use the same
things and and you know eg
you know velocity uh you know does
velocity um
you know does it bounce
from a boundary
does it you know
is it
all those kinds of issues yeah
so i think those things are probably i
mean again i think this is probably that
the right thing is is just that you know
if your agents happen to use special
magic keys like position and velocity
you know
and you set you know certain options
either as options or as something as
part of the rule or as something as part
of the kind of
initial state specification
you know if you specify that oh by the
way i'm running on a taurus then it
should just sort of magically update
those magic parameters right so the
basic point is for position and velocity
etc allow it to work like physical space
make it easy to work like physical space
well by that you mean stuff like
boundary conditions
yeah but also um
uh well i was thinking of yes i guess
stuff like boundary conditions but the
point is that you could imagine
something else which is euclidean
thing but it isn't actually physical
position
and i think that's an exotic case i
think the only case where people
actually want physical like stuff like
velocity turns into position and so on
is
well that's not even right that's not
even right
there's internal degrees of freedom that
you can imagine
like spinning turtles and things
where
well that's pretty exotic
um
okay
wave is commenting that uh someone has
been doing tutorials on every single
void behavior that's interesting we'll
look those up
um
uh nested systems okay that's
interesting have to look that up
and james maybe you could make some
notes from these items
um
[Music]
yes okay great stand on applications
that run performance shader rendered
boyds
uh
we are we have got a lot of stuff to do
with shaders now i mean if you want
realistic birds
uh you know
i i think we can make fairly realistic
birds at this point although i i don't
think we can do if there's some neat
hack for having
the boys interact with um
uh you know not doing all the ray
tracing again
we certainly don't have any of that
stuff
um
okay ali is commenting on on and off
lattice
yes we yeah that's the point made here
on and off lattice um simulations
uh
okay
um
let's see
um
okay
uh
ethan is complaining about lack of
reinforcement learning
that as i as i've been saying here that
was more a design problem
than an implementation issue
just because the things we ended up with
in designs were just so unbelievably
complicated we didn't believe that
anybody would be able to use them
and you know we have a few specific
examples but that's about it
um
and i'd love to get suggestions about
how to do better design for this and
yeah active classification is a function
that people don't use
and
you know is that because of bad design
or bad implementation i don't really
know
um
uh comments about generative
design boy um
the uh
um
yeah you know generative design is
something which seems to i mean i'm very
big on that kind of thing from cellular
automata and other such things
and you know it keeps on going up and
coming down again and i i'd love to um
you know i see these demos occasionally
where people show oh we made these with
genetic algorithms and it's a
wonderfully shaped new
way of making a can opener or something
um but you know i keep on seeing these
demos but i i don't know whether maybe
this is happening in the world of cad
programs i think we lost roger who might
have comments on that
um
let's see
yeah marco is commenting a generalized
simulation plot we actually have system
model plot which is something that needs
to i agree that this needs to um
where did i have this this is compare
system model plot because system model
plot has a lot of ways
to hook into that might be a good model
for that
um
because it has all sorts of defaults and
so on and so on and so on for making the
default plot of
the the
you know the simulation in this case
um
and uh
let's see hold on one second
um
okay
let's see so
uh
flexibility ethan says do you want to
have flexibility in specifying the goals
to optimize for
yeah i see this is the policy this is
policy optimization this is what the
kind of thing roger was talking about
with um
uh you know swarm control and so on what
did he call it distributed control
systems
yeah that's complicated um
uh
let's see
yeah this is
yeah ethan is commenting we should have
our machine learning people here um and
uh uh yeah we didn't think this was
going to go in a machine learning
direction
um
okay repast framework
okay should look at that i don't never
heard of it
that's what i like about these live
streams as we learn about some um
all these different
ideas
um
okay never heard of this thanks
um
ah people don't use a certain model
things they want to generate novel and
optimal strategies
i see
okay fair point
as in a search
for given given this i mean but you have
to have a model for the system but you
have to have an environment that you're
modeling otherwise
there's nothing to optimize
okay nick is commenting
that what is there to design rl
environment rl model rl train done
okay prove it
i i mean if that's the case wonderful
that
you know that wasn't what um um
uh
um
um
[Music]
yeah and ethan is commenting that the
core problem is that net train doesn't
support multiple ports within co within
encoders
um
yeah i mean this is yes the whole
redoing of this framework to generalize
it is something under steam okay wave is
commenting
um okay there's a lot of good
suggestions here about generative
well generative art is a little
different than generative cad design and
so on i think
um
uh you know and i'm aware of many of the
things you mentioned but not all of them
um
yeah well
i'm glad it's alive and well because you
know we from
you know we have been involved in this
for a long long time from from such
distinguished
uh
things as
the famous uh you know famous things
like this
um and uh and many other um efforts in
generative um
uh
generative visual design
um
uh that that um
yes
right well we should probably wrap up
for now for here but thank you all for
those for those suggestions and um
uh we will continue another time and try
and uh
nail this down a bit a little bit more
so
uh
thanks everyone
and